Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 125.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und ja, nachdem wir in der letzten Sendung uns schon wieder über Teleskope unterhalten
haben, werden wir uns wieder über Teleskope unterhalten.
Heute bin ich nach München gefahren, genauer nach Garching in den Forschungspark,
wo ja allerlei illustre Forschungsgruppen situiert sind.
Unter anderem das ESO, das European Southern Observatory, die Organisation,
die zuständig ist für den Betrieb und die Forschung, mit und an Teleskopen,
die auf der Südhalbkugel stehen.
Und ja, heute geht es ums Extremely Large Telescope und alles, was damit zu tun hat.
Und da begrüße ich erstmal meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Bertrand.
Bertrand Köhler, hallo.
Hallo, oder grüß Gott, wie man sagt, Bayern.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Bertrand, du bist ja schon sehr lange
hier in dieser Organisation, eigentlich schon immer, oder?
Fast. 35 Jahre eigentlich, 34 Jahre.
Okay, also eine Institution innerhalb der Institution.
Ja, eine von den Dinosaurern, sage ich gern.
Genau, weil das war für mich auch das Idealplatz für mich, deswegen bin ich geblieben.
Ja, warum war denn das ein idealer Platz? Erzähl doch mal, wie du zur Wissenschaft gekommen bist.
Ja, gerne. Ich muss vielleicht bis zum Alter von 13 Jahren alt.
Das tut mir leid, aber ich werde nicht alle Jahre erzählen. Das finde ich zu lang.
Aber als ich 13 Jahre alt war, habe ich Astronomie entdeckt.
Ich war im Urlaub in Normandie in Frankreich. Wie man hört, ich bin Franzose.
Und ich war mit meinem besten Freund dort in seinem Haus, mit seinen Eltern.
Und sein Vater hat plötzlich ein Teleskop gebracht, ein kleines Refraktor.
Er hat sich das immer gewünscht. Das war ein Traum, ein Kindentraum von ihm.
Und wir haben dann durchgeguckt. Und glücklicherweise gab der Mund,
der Mund, die nicht ganz voll war.
Weißt du, es ist wichtig, dass sie nicht voll ist, sondern dass man die Karte gut sieht.
Sie muss halb sein oder weniger ein Viertel oder was weiß ich.
Sodass man die Schatten auf dem Krater gut sieht.
Und das, was man heißt, Terminator, glaube ich, heisst das zumindest auf Englisch.
Weil das Licht dann von der Seite kommt.
Genau. Und auch Saturn war da, mit einer guten Position, wo man den Ring gut gesehen hat.
Und diese zwei Objekte waren für mich ein richtiges Aha-Erlebnis, wie man sagt.
Erst der Mond, man könnte die Krater sehr gut sehen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich fliege über diesen Krater und ich war schon immer
von Fliegen begeistert und interessiert.
Und der Saturn war auch ein Objekt, das hat für mich ausgesehen wie ein Schmuck,
wie ein kosmischer Schmuck, diese sehr feinen Ringe.
Ich bin wirklich sehr begeistert geworden und danach,
meine Eltern haben mir auch ein paar Jahre später ein Teleskop geschenkt und
ich habe auch weiter selber beobachtet und auch ein bisschen wissenschaftlich schon versucht,
mich zu beschäftigen.
Zum Beispiel habe ich versucht, die Satelliten von Jupiter zu zeichnen,
wie Galilei gemacht hat damals.
Und ich habe sogar versucht, die Laufbeine zu rechnen, aber das war schon ein
bisschen zu schwierig für mich. Auf jeden Fall, das war der Start.
Welches Jahr? In welchem Jahr befinden wir uns jetzt gerade?
Oh, das war 13, das war 75, also so 74.
Okay, also Raumfahrt gab es schon.
Aber ich versuche gerade mal so zu erinnern, was man eigentlich wusste über
das Weltall, weil die Wissensmenge hat ja seitdem extrem zugenommen.
Und was waren denn so die Unknowns damals, was wusste man denn alles noch nicht,
was man heute schon über das Weltall weiß?
Du hast ja an einigen Durchbrüchen teilgenommen.
Erstmal, ich bin diese Generation, die als Kind diese Mondlandung gesehen hat,
auf dem Fernseher, nämlich ganz kleines Fernseher, schwarz und weiß.
Und meine Eltern haben uns in der Nacht geweckt, das war ein sehr beeindruckvolles Erlebnis.
Und ich hatte schon ein gutes Gefühl,
ein gutes Verstand oder Bewusstsein von Raumfahrt und von dem Mond,
dass alles leer ist da draußen,
dass es auch viel Radiation gibt, aber es gab nicht so viele Satelliten,
aber ich habe auch geträumt, Astronaut zu werden.
Für mich war das Thema schon relativ präsent.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn ich versuche, die Unterschiede zu sehen,
natürlich, jetzt weiß man viel mehr, aber für mich persönlich sehe ich keinen großen Unterschied.
Ich war schon begeistert und wüsste, wie das ist da oben.
Mit anderen Worten, es war klar, es muss die Wissenschaft sein für dich.
Ja, und danach habe ich eigentlich Luft- und Raumfahrtingenieur studiert in
Toulouse, die Hauptschule, Ingenieurschule in Frankreich.
Und habe immer auch Astronomie parallel gemacht. Ich habe meinen Master parallel
zu meinen Ingenieurstudien gemacht in Astronomie.
Auch mein Projekt in der Schule, in der Ingenieurschule war auch für Astronomie
immer. Ich habe alle immer das gemischt.
Aber dann habe ich entschieden, ich bleibe mit meinem Ingenieurdiplom,
weil es war irgendwie leichter, Arbeit zu finden in der ganzen Welt.
Weil ich war auch immer interessiert an internationaler Umgebung oder Kultur.
Ich wollte nicht in meinem Dorf in Frankreich.
Wobei ja Toulouse schon so ein bisschen eine Weltraumhauptstadt ist in Frankreich,
das kann man ja wohl sagen.
Ja, ich bin in Paris groß geworden. Für mich nach Toulouse zu gehen,
war schon für mich auch ein Anfang von Weltentdeckung.
Ja, genau. Und dann musste ich meinen Militärdienst machen, als Zivil.
Damals hieß Kooperation, das war eine Möglichkeit, dass wir hatten,
wenn man eine Universität und Engenieurstudien hatte.
Man könnte im Ausland gehen und ein Jahr oder ein bisschen mehr,
eineinhalb Jahre, für einen guten Zweck, sagen wir, nutzen.
Typischerweise, das war in Afrika gehen, das war im Prinzip ein Nachfolger von
dieser Kolonialzeit, wo Frankreich hat gesagt, wir helfen diesen Ländern weiter.
Wir schicken junge Leute, die gut ausgebildet sind und als Lehrer für Mathe
oder für Französisch oder Physik oder so.
Aber damals hat es schon ein bisschen sich entwickelt und man könnte auch im Prinzip,
überall gehen, wenn man eine Stelle gefunden hat.
Damals wollte ich nach Brasil gehen, ich hatte schon eine Stelle,
aber im letzten Moment wurde es gekanzelt.
Ich war ein bisschen in meiner kritischen Situation.
Aber dann habe ich durch andere Kollegen oder Freunde, die auch in der Astronomie,
die ich durch Astronomie,
Sommercamp gekannt habe, sie haben mir gesagt, aber es gibt eine Sternwarte
in Chile, das heißt ESO, das ist eine europäische Sternwarte und sie nehmen
solche Cooperation zwei,
Jahre oder so und das war das erste Mal, dass ich von ESO hörte und dann habe ich mich bewerbt.
Und habe ich die Stelle bekommen und das war meine erste Begegnung mit ESO ich
war 24 oder so nicht richtig eingestellt, aber als diese Cooperation dort Ich war in La Silla,
das erste Sternwarte, das wir dort in Chile gebaut hatten. Mittlerweile haben wir mehrere.
Und eineinhalb Jahre war ich dort als Dienstastronom.
Im Prinzip musste ich den Astronomen helfen.
Damals war natürlich noch fast kein Computer.
Zur Steuerung des Teleskops schon, aber wir hatten nicht jeder einen Computer bei sich.
Und man musste den Astronomen helfen, nachmittags vor der Beobachtung zu checken,
was für Filter zum Beispiel sie brauchten auf dem Teleskop.
Es gab verschiedene Einstellungen zum Instrument zu machen.
Und das würde nicht per Computer einfach so gemacht. Man sollte vielleicht diese
Filter im Lager holen und ein Techniker musste das installieren.
Und ich war damals als die Zwischenstelle zwischen den Astronomen,
der arbeiten wollte und die Infrastruktur von Sternwarte, so die Techniker.
Und ich habe genau das Teleskop vorbereitet, sagen wir.
Und auch in der Nacht am Anfang waren wir dabei, um zu gucken,
ob alles gut funktioniert.
Und während der Astronomen noch Fragen hatten oder Probleme hatten,
musste ich das helfen, das zu lösen.
Genau, und auch am Punkt zu waren wir verantwortlich für die Nacht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn das Wind zu stark würde, musste man an das Teleskop anrufen
und sagen, bitte schließen jetzt und solche Sachen.
Das ist ja, glaube ich, 1969 begründet worden, Lassia als Standort,
wie du schon gesagt hast, der erste Standort der ESO, also im Prinzip der Beginn
dieser Organisationen.
Ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich weit draußen, also chilenische Bergwüste, da ist man sehr allein.
Wie ist es da zu sein?
Also ich meine, als du da angekommen bist als Zivildienstleister,
das ist ja auch immer ein sehr spezieller Einsatz für einen Zivildienst.
Wie fühlt man sich, wenn man da ankommt?
Ich bin begeistert, würde ich sagen. Das war für mich ein wirklich sehr angenehmes Erlebnis.
Ich war auch immer Bergsteiger, ich liebe die Berge, ich liebe diesen Freiraum.
Dort gibt es unglaublich viel Freiraum.
Man sieht sehr weit weg, man sieht sehr hohe Berge mit Schnee,
die weit weg sind, die näher sind, sind ganz kalt, weil das ist Wüste im Prinzip
oder dort in diesem Gebiet ist noch nicht die ganze richtige Atacama-Wüste,
die nämlich nördlich ist,
aber das ist, wie heißt das schon,
ja auf jeden Fall, das ist die dritte Region in Chile und es gibt schon ein
paar Kaktus, aber trotzdem sehr trocken.
Soja, das ist ein wunderschöner Ort. Und eigentlich ist ein Teil von der Motivation
für mich, für Astronomie zu arbeiten, dass die Sternwarte immer im extrem schönes Naturgebiet sind.
Das ist auch für mich etwas, was mir immer sehr getaugt hat. oder gefallen hat.
Der 13-Jährige hat bestimmt gejubelt jetzt, in der Dunkelheit.
Ja, ich meine, damals, das war schon zehn Jahre später, so 24,
glaube ich, aber ja, das war unglaublich.
Also der innere 13-Jährige, den meine ich, der hat gejubelt.
Absolut.
Kann ich gut verstehen. Ja, mit anderen Worten, damit war es dann für dich dann
auch entschieden, dass du dabei bleibst.
Ja, obwohl ich trotzdem eine Erfahrung in der Industrie haben wollte.
Ich bin danach, nach diesem Zivildienst, in der Industrie 3,5 Jahre,
im Südfrankreich, im Cannes.
Damals hieß es Aerospatial, ich glaube, jetzt gehört es zum Thales.
Und ja, sie haben Satelliten gebaut, aber auch, und deswegen bin ich dort gegangen,
haben sie Studien gemacht und auch Sachen gebaut für ESO.
Ich meine, ja, es gab ein Studium für ESO, das war für mich ein guter Mittel,
um weiter in Kontakt mit ESO zu sein, weil ich wüsste, irgendwann möchte ich dort arbeiten.
Internationale Umgebung, Astronomie, unglaublich interessantes Projekt,
Etwas, das man nie findet in Frankreich oder auch in Deutschland.
Genau, und ich war verantwortlich für ein Projekt als ganz junger Ingenieur
und das war für mich schon sehr spannend, für das Bauen von einer Deleline.
Eine Deleline ist ein bisschen schwierig zu erzählen, aber das war für einen
Interferometer, der im Südfrankreich im Dikaler Sternwarte war.
Das gehört zum NIS, NISA, Sternwarte.
Und ja, im Prinzip ist hier ein kleiner Teleskop, das horizontal sich bewegt,
sehr genau, um die optische Länge in einem Interferometer auszugleichen.
Ich glaube, bis jetzt reicht diese Erklärung. Man kann später ein bisschen das
weiter erklären, wenn nötig.
Aber das war ein Projekt auch für Interferometrie und diese Interferometrie
ist etwas, das mich als ich das entdeckt habe, als ich im Rasier war dieses Prinzip von,
das Licht von zwei Teleskopen zu kombinieren, coherently.
Und damit kriegt man eine Information, das erlaubt,
die Auflösung von das Bild von Sternen zu simulieren, wie ob man ein Teleskop
hätte, der als Durchmesser die Distanz zwischen dem zweiten Teleskop hätte.
Das bedeutet, man kann virtuell ein riesiges Teleskop bauen.
Natürlich, das hat nicht die gleiche Empfindlichkeit, weil Es sind nur zwei kleinere Teleskope,
aber die Auflösung, die Spatial Resolution auf Englisch, diese räumliche Auflösung, wird extrem gut,
extrem kleine, millerxigen.
Und ich fand das faszinierend und deswegen war für mich auch dieses Projekt sehr interessant.
Und auch deswegen bin ich nach ESO irgendwann nach dreieinhalb Jahren,
so 1991, gekommen, weil er angefangen hat, dieses VLT, Very Large Telescope,
zu bauen, das war schon entschieden.
Und kurz davor, ich glaube in 1986 war das entschieden.
Das war schon im Bau, noch nicht im Bau, aber im Design.
Und das war klar, dass ESO auch ein Interferometer damit machen wollte.
So dieses riesige 8 Meter Durchmesser-Teleskop von VLT wollte ISO,
also sagen wir die Community, die europäische astronomische Gemeinschaft,
wollte damit auch ein Tint-Differometer machen.
Und das war für mich eine unglaubliche Attraktion oder wie sagt man,
Anziehkraft, weil ich fand das Prinzip von Indre-Von-Tri faszinierend und auch
dann ISO und dieses riesige Projekt.
Deswegen bin ich seit 1991 hier gekommen als Systemingenieur.
So im Prinzip das Hauptingenieur, die ja,
das Zusammenhang von allen möglichen Komponenten, die Mechanik,
die Optik, die Steuerung und so zusammenfassen muss.
Und das war für mich eine unglaublich gute Erfahrung. Das war natürlich ein
Risiko auch, weil man hat noch nie so einen Interferente gebaut.
Damals, genau im Nizza, wofür ich diese Dele Line gebaut habe,
gab es schon in den 60er Jahren, der Antoine Laberé hat dieses Prinzip wieder
versucht zu implementieren und das hat schon geklappt.
Er hat diese Interferenz Fringe, ich weiß nicht, wie man das heißt,
Interferenz Fringes, auf jeden Fall, er hat Interferenz bekommen, aber das war.
Nur 20 Zentimeter Teleskop und das hat auch so, so funktioniert.
Man könnte sehen, kann funktionieren, aber es ist nicht so gut funktionieren.
Und jetzt, wir wollten diese 8 Meter Durchmesser Teleskop kombinieren.
Und eigentlich viele Kollegen hier, als ich gekommen habe, haben mir gesagt,
aber warum arbeitest du auf dieses Projekt, dass wir nie funktionieren?
Und am Ende, das war eine gute Wette, weil jetzt sieht man, es gibt mittlerweile
Zwischen 2022 sind ungefähr 450 Referie-Paper publiziert worden.
Das ist fast vier pro Monat. Und zum Beispiel dieser Nobelpreis im Jahr 2020 von Gerhard Gensel,
die gegenüber dem Max-Planck-Institut, gegenüber der Straße arbeitet,
hat auch WLTI benutzt, um diese Laufbahn von Sternen um das Schwarze Loch im
Zentrum unserer Galaxie zu messen.
Und diese endgültige Genauigkeit hat er bekommen durch VLTI.
Er hat schon vorher angefangen mit Adaptive Optics, mit viel anderer Sache.
Er war übrigens einer, die sehr viel gepusht hat für VLTI.
Er war wirklich ein sehr wichtiger Mensch, von außen von außen.
Es hat gesagt, jetzt baut das bitte.
Ja, da sind wir eigentlich schon von der persönlichen Geschichte schon fast
beim Thema angekommen, beziehungsweise wir sind bei der Art von Teleskopen angekommen,
für die ESO jetzt besonders bekannt ist.
Ich würde sagen, das ist so die Kategorie von, ich weiß nicht,
wie man das nennt, also generell Large Telescopes.
Also wirklich richtig große Spiegel und VLT,
was du erwähnt hast, gibt es seit 1998, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
dann an einem anderen Standort, nicht in dem La Silla, sondern ein anderer Berg,
alles nicht so weit voneinander entfernt.
Das ist dann der Zerro Paranal und dort waren es dann halt gleich vier von diesen
Teleskopen, die dann zusammengeschlossen wurden.
Also quasi die virtuelle Auflösung
ist dann eben extrem hoch durch die beschriebene Interferometrie.
Aber jedes Teleskop für sich ist ja schon ein ziemlicher Klotz mit acht Metern,
gehört es also auch heute noch so mit zu den größeren Spiegeln, die so unterwegs sind.
Jetzt ist ja, vielleicht sollten wir nochmal so ein bisschen was zum Standort
an sich sagen, also Chile wird ja nicht ohne Grund ausgewählt.
Ich glaube am Anfang hat man weit geforscht, okay, wo würde es sinnvoll sein,
überhaupt ein Bodenteleskop, ein großes aufzubauen.
Es gab natürlich schon überall welche auf der Welt.
Ich glaube, am Anfang war so Afrika ein bisschen im Blick, aber letzten Endes
ist ja Chile zum Superstandort geworden,
weil diese Wüsten so trocken sind und weil man eben einen entsprechend guten
Blick hat. Es gibt Platz, es gibt Berge.
Also ja, es ist ein bisschen.
Die Bodenteleskope spielen ja eine wichtige Rolle, weil sie halt einfach den
Vorteil haben, dass man sie permanent weiter betreiben kann,
dass sie rund um die Uhr in Betrieb sein kann, dass man permanent warten kann,
während natürlich Teleskope im All auch ihre Vorteile haben,
aber natürlich ungleich viel teurer sind,
natürlich nicht so eine lange Laufzeit haben und vor allem nicht so groß sein können.
Und die großen Teleskope sind viel größer. Man kann größer bauen, das ist das Hauptpunkt.
Man könnte nicht ein 39 Meter Teleskop behalten oder sogar ein 8 Meter.
Ich meine jetzt, der GWST ist fast 8 Meter, nicht ganz.
Man hat Tricks gefunden, das groß zu machen, aber es ist ein Riesenaufwand.
Jetzt wollen wir ja über das ELT sprechen und das Ding ist ein Monster.
Ich war selber auch mit Raumzeit auf La Palma, den kanarischen Inseln.
Dort steht ja das große Gran Canaria Teleskop, was rein technisch gesehen,
glaube ich, derzeit der größte Spiegel ist mit 10,40 Meter.
Es gibt dann in Hawaii noch das KEK-Teleskop. Das ist alles so diese Kategorie von großen Teleskopen,
man sagt jetzt großer Spiegel, aber es ist ja nicht ein Spiegel,
sondern es sind ja viele Spiegel, die zusammen einen Spiegel ergeben,
weil man so einen großen Spiegel alleine gar nicht bauen könnte,
schon gar nicht in der benötigten Präzision.
Jetzt hat die ESO ja sehr viel Erfahrung mit dem VLT gesammelt,
was war denn jetzt sagen wir mal die primäre Motivation zu sagen okay,
Jetzt drehen wir alles auf 11 und wir bauen so ein Megading,
weil ELT, wir haben es schon erwähnt, 39 Meter Durchmesser schlägt ja sozusagen
alles, was bisher da gewesen ist, nicht nur so um ein bisschen,
sondern es ist ja eine komplett neue Dimension von Spiegelgröße.
Was sind so die Treiber gewesen, die diesen Beschluss und dann natürlich auch
die technische Entwicklung so in die richtige Richtung gelenkt haben?
Ja, die Treiber ist immer die Wissenschaft natürlich und größer ein Teleskop
ist, mehr Licht er bekommt.
So schwache Sterne oder Galaxien kann man beobachten.
Aber auch ein Teleskop hat eine Grenze, das heißt die Diffraction Limit.
Das ist die Dimension von dem Bild am Fokus vom Teleskop. und auch ohne Atmosphäre,
ohne nichts, mit perfekter Optik.
Dieses Bild wird nicht unendlich klein.
Sie wird nie kleiner als diese Diffraktion-Limit. Das ist ein physikalisches Phänomen,
weil die Hauptspiegel nicht unendlich groß ist, sondern ein Diameter D, sagen wir, hat.
Es gibt einen Diffraktionen-Effekt am Rand von Spiegel und das macht,
dass das Bild eine Bedeutung.
Ein bisschen wie eine Gausch-Funktion.
Achso, eine Gausch-Verteilung.
Ja, ein bisschen wie eine Gausch-Verteilung hat. Und die Durchmesser von dieser
Gausch wird kleiner, wenn das Teleskop größer ist.
Und das ist wirklich etwas, man kann nur das Teleskop größer machen,
sonst kann man absolut nichts dagegen machen.
Da ist das Meta sozusagen.
Ja, und deswegen größer, besser.
Aber natürlich, man muss auch die Atmosphäre korrigieren, weil wenn man größer
macht, diese Turbulenz von der Atmosphäre wird das Bild stören.
Und um wirklich diese Größe davon zu profitieren, muss man schon die Turbulenz
von der Atmosphäre korrigieren, das was man nennt adaptive Optics.
Und mit Vorschritt von dieser Technik, das würde auch dann erlaubt,
dass ein größerer Teleskop schon seinen Vorteil haben kann, den Vorteil von diesem großen Spiegel,
weil man kann auch die Atmosphäre korrigieren und der ELT ist der erste Teleskop, der so konzipiert ist,
zumindest beim ESO, aber ich glaube weltweit, ja, glaube ich,
aber LBT hatte schon eine, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das von Anfang an geplant ist.
Auf jeden Fall, das hat eine Adaptive Optics drin im Teleskop.
Früher hat man das am Fokus gemacht, nach dem Teleskop, und hier ist wirklich
drin, was noch besser ist für verschiedene technische Gründe.
Ja, also die Motivation ist wirklich das wissenschaftliche Ziel,
dass man weiter gucken kann.
Und auch bessere räumliche Auflösung.
Und wann ging das dann los mit dem Projekt? Wann hat man sich dazu entschlossen, das anzugehen?
So als das Foil zum Ende kam oder installiert wurde, ich habe schon ein paar
Ingenieure hier, die sich gelangweilt haben.
Und sie haben schon angefangen und das war eigentlich ein noch größerer Teleskop
zu entwickeln oder nachzudanken.
Denken das war sehr früh noch gedenken sagen
wir das war ein 100 meter durchmesser das ist das hat ein sehr guter name eigentlich
vielleicht merkt man dass es so nicht besonders gut ist im akronen das ist nicht
sehr kreativ vlt very large ilt extrem aber diese hat ein sehr guter akronen das Das war AULE,
Overwhelming Large Telescope.
AULE ist natürlich das. Die Eule. Ja, die Eule.
Sie haben schon sehr gut gearbeitet und gezeigt, dass das fast machbar wurde.
Aber die Gremium, die das so kontrolliert, sagen wir, unser Council,
irgendwann hat gesagt, ja, aber das ist schon zu viel Risiko für die Organisation.
Wir wollen nicht dieses Risiko angehen.
Und deswegen haben sie gesagt, okay, aber wir wollen natürlich Grösse bauen, aber nicht so groß.
Und dann kamen die 42 Meter und dann das war ein bisschen zu teuer.
Dann hat man das reduziert auf 39 Meter.
Und diese endgültige, sagen wir, Definition von das ELT war im Jahr 2010 ungefähr,
2012. In 2012 hat unsere Council gesagt, jetzt wollen wir dieses Projekt bauen.
Aber es gab noch kein Geld, nicht genug, sagen wir. Und damals sollte Brasilien
als Mitgliedsstadt in ESO kommen.
Und das hätte natürlich auch Geld dazu gleich bringen müssen.
Und das war nötig, um das ELT anzufangen.
Aber irgendwie ist das nicht passiert. Und deswegen sind wir von 1942 auf 1939
gekommen. und ein paar andere Änderungen, sodass das finanzierbar war,
ohne eine zusätzliche Mitgliedstaat.
Und so war der Anfang 2014, war wirklich das grüne Licht, um anzufangen,
weil wir hatten genug Finanzen dafür.
Okay, das ist jetzt gerade mal elf Jahre her. Wann erwartet man die Inbetriebnahme derzeit?
Derzeit ist, das Teleskop sollte im März 29 fertig sein und die wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse,
die erste wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse sind vor Ende 2030 erwartet.
Also dauert noch ein bisschen, aber das Ding ist im Bau und ist natürlich auch
schon komplett spezifiziert.
Ich bin hier auch gerade ein bisschen rumgelaufen, hier gibt es ja auch einen
Raum, wo Technik getestet und zusammengebaut wird.
Da sind dann auch schon Einzelteile, die später dann nach Chile geliefert werden zu sehen.
Wie findet man jetzt den Standort für so ein Projekt?
Ja, das ist immer ein relativ langer Prozess.
Man kennt mittlerweile natürlich immer besser die verschiedenen Standorteigenschaften.
Aber für ALT, wir wollten von Anfang an wieder kümmern.
Es gab sogar in Kasachstan oder so einen Ort.
Aber sehr relativ schnell, 2010 gab es eine erste Zwischenbilanz und waren vier
Standorte in Chile genannt und auch La Palma im Kanarien Island, in der Insel.
Genau und was wichtig ist natürlich gibt es erst zwei Sachen,
sagen wir, die atmosphärische Bedingungen und auch die.
Bodeneigenschaft sagen wir und als dritte auch die Logistik Aspekt und für atmosphärische
Bedingungen sind viele Parameter, die Turbulenz ist sehr wichtig,
das muss eine sehr stabile Atmosphäre ohne viel Turbulenz.
Die Windgeschwindigkeit ist die Instinktion, wie durchlässig ist die Atmosphäre
in diesem Ort, das hängt ein bisschen ab von Ort.
Die Wolkendeckung natürlich, wir wollen keine Wolken.
Die Luftfeuchtigkeit, die Wasserdampfgehalt, ich meine, es gibt wirklich viele Parameter.
Und am Ende, die Atacama-Wüste hat diese Eigenschaft, dass das sehr trocken
ist, weil es gibt zwei Sachen, sagen wir, Hauptsache, die Humboldt-Strömung,
das ist eine Strömung im Pazifik,
die kommt von Antarktika und ist kalt.
Und deswegen, diese Pazifik ist kalt, ist nicht sehr gut für Baden,
man muss nicht unbedingt nach Chile gehen,
aber das macht eine Inversionsschicht und alle Feuchtigkeit bleibt niedrig,
bleibt unten in den ersten 500 Meter,
Maximum 800 Meter.
So alle Wolken bleiben nah am Meer, weil das ist kalt.
Das ist die erste. Und dann gibt es auch ein,
Meta-Konvektion-Zell über die Pazifik und man kann sich das wie eine Konvektion-Zell
sich vorstellen und das geht hoch über Australien.
Die Luft dann wird, es wird viel regnen dort, ich meine über die Pazifik im
Prinzip und das Luft kommt von oben, sehr trocken, weil da oben sehr kalt und
sehr trocken und kommt runter wieder über Chile.
Diese kalte Luft, die kommt von oben, ist sehr trocken und deswegen ist es eine
Atacama-Wüste, aber auch deswegen gibt es auch keine Wolken.
Diese zwei Effekte kombinieren sich, um einen unglaublich guten Standort zu machen für Astronomie.
Da kann dann auch Kasachstan nicht mithalten.
Ja, genau.
Ich meine, der Standort hat natürlich auch noch zahlreiche andere Vorteile,
allein schon, weil jetzt in Chile so eine große Wissenschafts-Community ja ohnehin
schon zusammengekommen ist. Das macht sicherlich den Betrieb auch einfacher.
Ja, aber das war nicht das Haupt. Wirklich, der Fokus war auf die Qualität.
Und dieser Logistik-Aspekt hat natürlich auch beigetragen, um Amazonas statt
andere Berge, die es in Chile auch gab.
Aber genau, das war der Entschluss.
Aber wie findet man dann den finalen Berg? Ja.
Also ich meine, es gibt ja viele Berge da unten und das ist ja ein Riesengebiet.
Da könnte man ja sagen, okay, nehmen wir einfach den nächsten.
Also misst man dann jetzt wirklich nochmal auf dem jeweiligen Berg oder sind
das rein geologische Aspekte oder logistische Aspekte?
Nein, man misst schon, weil es gibt auch lokale Effekte.
Ein Tal zum Beispiel kann die Turbulenz ein bisschen ändern,
diese Bodenschicht-Turbulenz, die normalerweise irgendwann auch verschwindet
nachts, aber am Anfang des Nachts zum Beispiel kann es schon stören.
Man misst schon die Turbulenz überall und auch der Wind. Der Wind kann anders sein.
Übrigens, auf Amazonas ist relativ viel Wind, das ist nicht ein Pluspunkt von
Amazonas, aber das ist schon machbar.
Man muss die Sache dimensionieren und eventuell muss man beobachten,
die Gegenrichtung von Wind.
Das machen wir sowieso auch schon auf Paranal.
Ja, und Amazonas war auch sehr viel gemessen worden, Erst von ESO vor VLT.
Und als wir einen Standort für Veräulte gesucht haben, haben wir schon auch
mal so einen Blick gehabt, weil das ist höher, das ist 3000 Meter statt 2500.
Und höher ist besser für Infrarot, weil weniger Wasserdampfgehalt.
Wir wüssten schon von lange her dass das auch ein gutes Ding ein gutes Berg war,
allerdings ein bisschen kälter wie gesagt aber auch die Amerikaner das TMT Projekt
das ist ein ähnliches Projekt wie ELT ein bisschen weniger,
TMT steht für 30 Meter Telescope 30 Meter statt 38 aber es ist ein Projekt das
jetzt läuft obwohl sie schon ein großes Problem gehabt haben,
wir können darüber sprechen, sind nicht so weit wie uns, aber,
sie hatten diesen Ort gewählt schon.
Der Berg war schon besetzt im Prinzip und man muss sagen, wir haben auch ein
bisschen Glück gehabt, dass irgendwann Japan wollte dieses Projekt sich anschließen,
aber auf die Bedingungen, dass das Teleskop in Hawaii gebaut wurde,
weil sie haben schon ein Teleskop des GLT,
japanische Large Telescope.
Und deswegen sind wir dann weggegangen von Amazonessen und haben das Platz für uns gemacht.
Und sie hatten viel gemessen und wir haben davon natürlich profitiert.
Ich glaube, das Sati-Mita-Teleskop hatte auch in Hawaii noch Probleme,
da gibt es eine Menge Proteste deswegen.
Das war leider für sie keine gute Sache, weil in Hawaii haben sie viele Probleme gehabt und immer noch.
Und sowieso gab es noch mehr Probleme.
Auch jetzt mit der aktuellen Administration ist nur eine von den zwei,
weil sie hatten zwei Projekte, GMT und TMT.
Und jetzt ist nur einer, das ist im Prinzip das GMT, die weiterentwickelt wurde.
Aber das ist eine schwierige Situation und wir sind auch sehr traurig davon,
weil natürlich, man kann sagen, wir sind Kompetitor,
wir ein bisschen kompetieren, um die Erste zu sein, aber wir arbeiten auch viel
zusammen und unsere Ziel ist die Wissenschaft.
Egal wo das ist, ist es wichtig, dass solche Teleskopzustände kommen.
Ja und das bringt einen ja auch selber voran, wenn andere Technologien ausprobieren,
Probleme lösen, dann kann man davon ja auch lernen und die eigene Technik verbessern
und die eigenen Prozesse optimieren.
Absolut.
Okay, also Cerro Armazones heißt der Berg,
ist ungefähr eine Stunde, glaube ich, entfernt, wenn man mit dem Auto fährt von La Silla,
von einem anderen Standort und dann ist man irgendwie noch weiter im chilenischen
Hinterland und höher und dann wurde dort begonnen auch mit dem Bau.
Wie sucht man jetzt, also meine, das ist ja ein...
Unglaublich komplexes Projekt. Man denkt sich so, Spiegel, ein paar Motoren
dran, zack, bumm, Klappe auf, kommt schon.
Man muss ja unheimlich viel berücksichtigen. Wir hatten schon den Wind,
ich glaube in der Gegend gibt es auch mal Erdbeben.
Richtig, ja. Große sogar.
Große sogar. Ist ja jetzt nicht das Beste für so einen Spiegel,
den man dann irgendwie nanometergenau ausrichten möchte.
Welche Partner holt man sich da ins boot um solche.
Probleme zu lösen so ich
glaube die erste frage ist wie geht man
um mit dieser komplexität und eine keyword eine
kernwort ist
system engineering das ist
auch meine spezialität so ich wäre ein bisschen dafür
aber nur durch
diese mindset diese dankweise kann
man solche projekte machen und diese dankweise
ist eigentlich die komplizität ein kleines stück zu beuckeln
oder zu verteilen aufzuteilen
zum beispiel ist wichtig dass dich die das bild von stern nicht wackelt im fokus
das heißt stabilität stabilität von von und man erst Erstmal sagen die Astronomen,
was für eine Stabilität sie brauchen, um ihre wissenschaftliche Beobachtung zu machen.
Und dann nehmen die Ingenieure diesen Wert und listen alle möglichen,
bestimmte Parameter, die das beeinflussen, zum Beispiel die Genauigkeit des
Antriebs des Teleskops.
Wenn das Antrieb irgendwie hackt, nicht ganz smooth, wie sagt man das, ganz leise.
Smooth ist, glaube ich, mittlerweile offiziell ein deutscher Begriff. Okay, gut.
Wenn das nicht ganz smooth läuft, hat man ein Problem. Aber auch der Wind über
das Teleskop wird die ganze Struktur zum Schwingen bringen.
Gerade wenn es so groß ist.
Ja, und Erdbeben, wir haben gesprochen, aber natürlich die großen Erdbeben beobachtet
man nicht, aber die kleinen, es gibt auch immer ein bisschen kleine,
muss man checken, ob das nicht diese Stabilität stören wird.
So diese ganze Liste macht man und dann für jede, man sagt, für diese Teile,
ich will nicht mehr als diese Störung haben.
Das heißt Error Budget, ein Fehlerbudget kann man sagen.
Das ist ein Beispiel, was System Engineering macht und was dieses komplette Projekt machbar macht,
weil man kontrolliert dann alle diese Quellen von Problemen oder von Ungenauigkeit
und man hat das im Blick, dass natürlich man muss das hier immer wieder neue Update machen,
weil neuere Erkenntnisse mit dem Design kann man wenn das Design steht für einen
Teil kann man berechnen wie viel schwingt zum Beispiel diese Teile und dann
in diese Fehler Budget reinbringen.
Aber auch Management ist wichtig, natürlich, weil man braucht Menschen,
um solche Projekte zu machen.
Und das ist auch wichtig, eine gute Struktur zu haben von einem Projekt,
von einem Management-Sichtpunkt.
Leute, die motiviert sind, die wissen genau, was sie machen müssen, gute Kommunikation.
Und auch natürlich sehr wichtig ist die Partnerschaft, so wie mit der Industrie,
aber auch mit dem wissenschaftlichen Instituten. Weil die Wissenschaftlichen
Instituten bauen im Prinzip die Instrumente.
Die sind in sich schon eine richtige Herausforderung. Die ILT-Instrumenten sind so groß wie ein Haus.
Und mit sehr viel Komplextechnik drin, Kryogenik und Spektral.
Hoche Auflösung, Spektral. Man braucht auch ganz spezielle Komponenten dafür, auch sehr stabil.
Und was die Industrie angeht, wir könnten nicht Tesco bauen ohne die wichtige
Industrie, die wir haben.
Und natürlich gibt es einige, die fast zum, ja, falls es geht,
Kollaborator sind, oder? Wir haben trotzdem natürlich Verträge,
wir geben Verträge, das ist eine Kunden- und Supplier-Beziehung, aber trotzdem,
wir arbeiten seit Jahrzehnten mit denen, ich kann für deutsche Industrie, ich kann Schott nennen.
Schott macht alle unsere Glas, diese Glaseramik, die heißt Zero-Dür,
die sich entwickelt haben in den 60er-Jahren, glaube ich.
Und das ist ein, das beste Material, um Spiegel zu machen, weil extrem stabil,
thermisch, stabil, Stabilität, man kann das gut polieren und so.
Das glaube ich mal für den Rosat-Satelliten ist das, glaube ich, mal erfunden worden.
Kann sein, ja. Und so Schott ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Sie haben alle diese Grundmaterien, diese Glaskeramik für alle Spiegel gemacht, außer M5.
M5 sind ganz spezielle Dinge mit Silikonkarbide.
M5 ist der Name. Mirror 5, einer der Ja.
Genau. Das ist der fünfte Spiegel im optischen Schema.
Und Safran-Riosk ist eine andere französische Firma, die fast alle unsere Spiegel poliert.
Und es ist weltweit wirklich Industrien, die an der Spitze sind.
Und das ist für uns natürlich extrem ein Muss, sonst könnte man Telescope nicht bauen.
Ich kann auch noch Heidenein nennen, in deutscher Firma auch.
Die baut alle diese.
Man muss sehr genau das Drehwinkel vom Teleskop messen, um das zu steuern,
weil man muss die Sterne folgen natürlich über die Nacht und das muss extrem
genau sein und Heidenheim ist ein ganz Spezialist und ein prinzipales Teleskop
der Welt fast, nützen diese Sensoren von Heidenheim.
Eine andere deutsche Firma ist Physikinstrumente, auch sehr wichtig für Piezo-Actuator,
Piezo-Technik und wir nützen das viel.
Zum Beispiel jedes Segment, jedes von diesen 798 Segmenten, das wir haben auf dem ELD M1,
werden durch drei Positioning-Aktuateuren, nennt man das, so kleine Motoren,
die das Spiegel bewegen können.
Und das ist vom Physik-Instrument entwickelt worden.
Ja genau, diese Zusammenarbeit mit Institut und mit Industrie ist auch ein Muss
für so große Projekte zu entwickeln.
Jetzt sowas in die Wüste zu schicken, heißt ja auch, dass man da Transport quasi
hin machen muss, relativ viel Material muss bewegt werden.
Wie hat sich denn, also das ist ja an sich schon mal ein großer Aufwand,
wie hat sich denn so diese Covid-Phase auf das Projekt ausgewirkt?
Ja, es hat sich sehr natürlich ausgewählt. Ich glaube, das Haupt,
oder was man mehr sieht, ist, dass die Baustelle dort im Amazon ist,
hat es schon angefangen.
Und sie waren dabei, diese Betongrundplatte zu gießen im Prinzip.
Und es ist eineinhalb Jahre fast, oder ein bisschen mehr als ein Jahr Pause, hat Pause gemacht.
Und natürlich in die industrie auch teilweise
könnten sie nicht mehr arbeiten oder
es noch wie mit sehr wenigen teams mit nur zwei drei leute so alle ist langsamer
geworden und das hat auch natürlich kosten gehabt es ist ja das war eine von die größten sagen wir,
ungeplante Störung,
weil es gibt immer Probleme.
Es ist klar, in diesem technisch hochentwickelten Projekt hat man ständig kleine
technische Probleme, aber sie werden gelöst.
Das nimmt ein bisschen Zeit, das verspätet ein bisschen das Projekt,
aber im Prinzip werden sie immer gelöst und das war natürlich nicht lösbar.
Und was den Transport angeht, weil ESO hat schon extrem lange Erfahrungen,
seit Jahrzehnte, wir schicken sehr empfindliche Teile und Spiegel dort.
So, wir wissen schon, wie man das macht.
Man muss natürlich die Packung sehr genau und sehr gut machen.
Sie sind in selbst hochentwickelten Container oder Box.
Aber man kontrolliert nicht alles. Auf einem Schiff, der Kapitän ist der Chef und er macht
was er will, egal was in Verträgen, es ist wie im Flugzeug.
So kann es immer passieren, dass es ein Problem gibt und er muss die Sache bewegen.
Und wir hatten einen Fall in den 90ern oder 2000, wo ein Spiegel kaputt gemacht
wurde im Brasil, durch eine schnelle Bewegung von Boxen.
So kann man das nicht ganz vermeiden, aber wir machen alles,
was wir können. zum Beispiel, das ist sehr wichtig, dass sie wissen,
dass es in dieser Kiste etwas sehr empfindlich gibt.
Das ist der erste Punkt, dass man sich ein Transportproblem führt dazu.
Dass der Spiegel beschädigt wird, egal wie gut man den einpackt,
die sind so hoch empfindlich, dass man die ganze Zeit wie rohe Eier transportieren muss.
Ja, ja. Aber wie gesagt, die Kiste sind so gemacht, dass das schon eine richtige,
großer Umfall sein, dass sie kaputt gehen.
Die müssen mehrere Meter runterfallen.
Kommen wir nochmal auf das Design von dem System.
Also wie ist jetzt das ELT konkret aufgebaut?
Wir haben hier und da schon gesagt, besteht aus 798 Segmenten,
also der Hauptspiegel, aber das ist ja auch nicht der einzige Spiegel.
Vielleicht können wir das mal so ein bisschen Wir nehmen mal das Licht aus dem
All, was quasi auf die Erde zuschießt und jetzt sich in Richtung dieses Spiegels bewegt.
Vielleicht können wir mal so diesen Weg nachvollziehen durch den Spiegel durch,
bis wir ein Bild oder eine Datensammlung haben.
Das ist schon eine Herausforderung.
Ja, bei Fall.
Mit deinem Bild, das ist ja leicht zu erklären, aber in Wörtern,
besonders für mich, finde ich nicht so einfach, aber versuchen wir.
So, das Licht kommt auf dem M1.
Naja, erstmal kommt es ja in die Atmosphäre. Also wir sind ja noch...
Fangen wir mal am Anfang an. Also Licht trifft auf die Erde auf und das ist
ja dann schon mal ein Problem.
Ja, weil die Atmosphäre hat nicht die gleiche Temperatur überall.
So gibt es kleine Bubbles, kleine Terminische Blasen.
Und das Licht in dieser Atmosphäre bewegt sich nicht an Lichtgeschwindigkeit
wie im Hall, sondern auf eine Geschwindigkeit, die abhängig ist von dem Index of Refraction.
Refraktion Index, glaube ich, sagt man wahrscheinlich.
Und deswegen, wenn ein Licht durch die warme Blase geht, geht es schneller im
Prinzip. wird schneller am Teleskop sein, als die andere, die in kalte Luft geht.
Und deswegen haben wir nicht eine schöne,
Welle, die kommt ganz flach auf den Spiegel, sondern es wird ein bisschen gebogen, sagt man.
Wie ein Metall, wie ein Auto, das einen Unfall hat.
So leicht verbogen.
Und das ist, was man mit Adaptive Optics danach wieder gut macht,
wieder korrigiert mit einem sehr dünnen Spiegel, die Gegenbewegung gegen,
Fehler korrigiert.
Das heißt, man muss die Atmosphäre eigentlich die ganze Zeit beobachten und
schauen, wie ist sie denn eigentlich verbogen?
Richtig.
Um diese Biegung dann wiederum im Spiegel selber zu korrigieren.
Ja, zu kompensieren.
Das ist die adaptive Optik.
Genau. Genau, und dafür hat man eine Kamera besonders entwickelt.
Ja, das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen kompliziert zu erklären,
wie das geht, aber das mittlerweile… Dafür.
Sind doch die Laser da, ne?
Auch, die Laser sind da, weil im Prinzip, man benutzt ein bisschen Licht von
diesen Sternen, zu messen, um diese Messung zu machen von Atmosphäre.
Aber man nimmt ein bisschen Photon und die Photon sind sehr teuer.
Die Wissenschaftler, die Astronomen wollen alle Photon haben im Prinzip.
Aber sie wollen auch ein gutes Bild. Sie geben ein bisschen Photon zu uns,
zum Korrigieren, aber manchmal, wenn das eine sehr schwache Sterne ist oder
eine Galaxie, hat man einfach nicht genug Photon.
Und da kommen die Laser im Spiel, weil mit diesem Laser, man kreiert einen künstlichen
Sterne im Hochatmosphäre, 90 Kilometer
entfernt, weil es gibt auch eine Ozonschicht, die durch diese Laser,
angeregt wird. und danach diese angeregten Atomenstrahlen,
in Richtung Erde, in Richtung Teleskop, wieder Photon.
Und deswegen dann hat man im Prinzip einen Stern, aber die künstlich ist.
Und die kann man positionieren, wo man will.
Neben dieser sehr schwachen Galaxie, die man beobachtet.
Im Prinzip so ein bisschen wie so eine Xbox, indem man so ein Pixelmuster auf
die Atmosphäre draufwirft.
Dann nimmt man das wiederum mit der Kamera auf, zusätzlich zu all den Sternen.
Und die Verzerrung der Atmosphäre durch die thermischen Ungleichmäßigkeiten
kann man dann im Prinzip wieder rauslesen.
Das heißt, wenn ich so eine klare Matrix hinschicke, mir anschaue,
wie das wieder zurückgestrahlt wird und ich habe dann Verzerrungen da drin,
dann sehe ich unmittelbar direkt die Verzerrung der Atmosphäre zu dem jeweiligen
Zeitpunkt und kann das dann wiederum durch die Spiegel oder später durch Software korrigieren.
Sehr gut zusammengefasst und in Hochdeutsch. Okay. Ja, ja, absolut. Absolut richtig.
Und dann könnte man auf diesen M1, so den Hauptspiegel.
Und dort mit diesem Segment muss man dieses Segment sehr gut genau kontrollieren,
sodass sie wirklich wie ein einziger Spiegel wirken.
Wie groß muss ich mir einen einzelnen Spiegel jetzt vorstellen?
1,5 Meter.
Hexagonal.
Aus diesem Serodur-Material.
Genau. Poliert. Jeder hat eine einzige Form, weil die gesamte Form von M1,
vom Hauptspiegel, ist nicht eine Sphäre, nicht eine Parabola,
ist viel komplizierter.
Und deswegen hat jeder Segment eine andere Form.
Das war die richtige Herausforderung, das nicht so viel zu polieren,
obwohl schon, aber auch zu messen. Die Messung ist immer das Schwierigste,
wenn man einen Spiegel poliert und wenn er nicht ganz einfach ist.
Was heißt genau eine andere Form? Also ich würde jetzt erstmal erwarten,
dass die wesentlichen sind, sie aber hexagonal.
Ja, die Form von dem Substrat, ja, aber die optische Oberfläche.
Achso, die Oberfläche ist unterschiedlich.
Das meinte ich.
Verstehe.
Genau, und dieses Segment muss man ganz genau positionieren,
sodass sie ebenbündig sind.
Und das wird auch gemessen durch eine andere Kamera, sagen wir,
spezialisiert dazu und mit diesen Motoren kompensiert oder kontrolliert.
Das heißt, die Motoren sind unterhalb dieser Spiegel angebracht?
Ja.
Verschiedene Motoren, also mehrere Motoren pro Spiegel, wie viele sind das?
Drei. Man braucht drei, weil mehr wäre ein Risiko, das Spiegel zu biegen,
weil es ist diese isostatische Konfiguration.
Also man braucht ein Dreieck und kann sozusagen dadurch, dass man dann diese
Motoren verschiebt, die aber dann sehr fein sich einstellen lassen,
kann man sozusagen dem Spiegel so eine leichte andere Biegung geben.
Biegung nicht, aber Positionierung. Eine Höhe und einen Winkel, diese zwei Winkel.
Also man verbiegt nicht den Spiegel, sondern man stellt die Position genau ein,
die dann im Konzert mit all den anderen 768 Spiegeln insgesamt dann quasi...
Die richtige Einstellung hat, um all das zu korrigieren, was man in dem Moment korrigieren kann.
Und dann das Licht wird wieder hochgehen zum M2.
M2, das zweite Spiegel, ist auch 4,2 Meter Durchmesser.
Schon relativ groß. Ich meine, die Große davon, die herkömmliche gute Teleskop,
aktuell, nicht diese VLT mit 8, aber die meiste Teleskope haben mittlerweile 4 Meter.
Und sie ist sehr hoch und diese ist auch extrem weit weg von einer einfachen Oberflächeform.
Aber das ist nur ein Segment dann?
Ja, das ist ein Substrakt.
Und dann, das kommt runter und das ist eine ganz spezielle Eigenschaft von ELT.
Das Licht wird auf einen Fokus gehen, die genau in der Mitte von einem anderen
Spiegel, dem vierten Spiegel, hat ein Loch da drin und das geht da durch.
Das ist ein bisschen speziell, aber das war ein ganz guter Trick,
das die Optiker, die das ELT entwickelt haben, gefunden haben.
Dann geht durch diese Spiegel ohne Einfluss von diesem vierten Spiegel.
Dann kommt auf M3, die in der Mitte von M1 ist,
dann geht wieder hoch auf diese M4 und diese M4 ist ein sehr dünnes Spiegel,
nur 1,9 Millimeter dick und das ist dieser Adaptive Optik Spiegel.
Er wird auch mit 5000 Aktuator, kleinen Motoren,
In diesem Fall sind Spule, sagt man, wie in meinem Lautsprecher,
die diesen sehr dünnen Spiegel biegt, um die Atmosphäre zu kompensieren.
Und danach geht es wieder auf ein M5, die ein bisschen auf der Seite ist,
das sind Flachspiegel, aber die kann sich sehr schnell auch bewegen im Winkel.
Und das ist wie in meiner Kamera, mittlerweile in aller Kamera gibt diese Spiegel die Bewegung.
Achso, das schnelle Ausgleich. Ja, genau.
Ich spreche von diesem Spiegel, die korrigiert die Bewegung,
die man macht, wenn man das Bild nimmt.
Dass das Bild nicht verwackelt.
Genau. Und das ist unser M5, unser fünftem Jahrer Spiegel, das wir vorher gesehen haben, gemacht.
Und dann ähnlich das Licht zum Instrument auf der Seite vom Teleskop.
Also um das nochmal genau zu verstehen, also der große Spiegel,
der tatsächlich 768 Spiegel gemeinsam sind,
ist ja kein durchgehender Spiegel, sondern der hat halt in der Mitte ein großes
Loch, also man hat eigentlich mehr so einen Spiegelring, den man braucht.
Das Licht, was dort auftrifft, das geht nach oben zu einem geschlossenen Spiegel,
M2, der aus einem einzelnen Segment besteht und der kein Loch in der Mitte hat.
Das heißt, das ganze Licht wird dann wiederum nach unten geworfen,
geht dann wiederum in der Mitte eines Spiegel.
Vierten Spiegels durch, um von unten, von einem anderen, von diesem dritten
Spiegel nach oben geworfen zu werden.
Da trifft es dann wieder auf diesen Ringspiegel.
Der schickt es dann so ein bisschen zur Seite, zu diesem schnelldrehenden,
ausgleichenden fünften Spiegel und dann hat man das quasi horizontal und dort
wird dann das eigentliche Bild wieder verarbeitet.
Das heißt, man hat eigentlich ursprünglich so ein Ringbild sozusagen.
Man hat eigentlich ein Bild, wo ein Loch in der Mitte ist.
Ja, aber alle Teleskope haben das. Weil der M2 ist sowieso etwas, was ein Loch macht.
M2 muss immer irgendwo in der Mitte von M1, von Sterne gesehen,
das ist ein Loch in der Mitte.
Eigentlich alle, fast alle. Man kann auf Axis bauen, auf Axis-Teleskop bauen,
aber so groß kann man nicht.
Aber das ist nur für kleinere Teleskope möglich.
Ja, was das macht, ist nicht so viel.
Das ändert ein bisschen diesen Diffraction-Pattern, was ich vorher gesprochen habe.
Das perfekte Bild, das man haben kann von diesem Teleskop, ist nicht ein Gaussian
oder sowieso ist es nicht ein Gaussian.
Die Form von diesem Diffraction-Bild ist ein bisschen anders, aber nicht viel anders.
Aber warum braucht man noch diesen dritten und den vierten Spiegel?
Warum kann man nicht direkt oben von dem zweiten Spiegel nach unten und dann
zur Seite und das war's? Warum?
Weil man bräuchte dafür ein M1, die extrem, das Licht extrem biegt. Und das ist,
Und auch optischerweise kann man nicht, das ist die Fokallenz,
die Länge von einer Kamera,
um einen sehr kurzen Fokalfokus zu haben, wie weit der Fokus ist von der Länge.
Wenn das sehr kurz ist, man braucht eine Linse, die extrem stark ist,
extrem gebogen ist oder extrem dick in der Mitte und gekrümmt ist.
Und das ist optischerweise sehr schwierig zu machen. Und auch wenn man ein bisschen
Sichtfeld haben will, nicht in der Mitte, weil in der Mitte kann man schon relativ
gut etwas Oberfläche von dieser Linse finden,
die ein gutes Bild macht in der Mitte.
Aber dann will man auch ein gutes Bild ein bisschen weiter entfernt im Sichtfeld
und das wird extrem schwierig zu machen.
Deswegen, diese verschiedenen Spiegel sind da, um die Länge von diesen Fokkeln zusammenzufalten.
Okay, also man verlängert quasi sein Blickfeld, ohne jetzt noch weiter in die
Höhe gehen zu müssen oder den Spiegel mehr krümmen zu müssen.
Also eine Notwendigkeit, einfach um das optisch einzufangen.
Und auch zum Beispiel der M4 für Adaptive Optics. Man könnte nicht diese Adaptive
Optics machen auf dem M1.
Das wäre zu groß, zu kompliziert. Man muss auch irgendwo einen Spiegel haben
in der Mitte von dieser ganzen Reihe, die nicht so groß ist,
obwohl es schon sehr groß ist für Adaptive Optics.
Aber ja genau, um auch diese Funktion in das Teleskop zu bauen,
ist es sehr hilfreich, mehrere Spiegel zu haben.
Okay, das heißt M4 macht die eigentliche Adaption auf die, also worauf ist es
adaptiv? Auf die atmosphärischen Bewegungen.
Aber korrigiert auch zufällig, zum Beispiel Schwingungen vom Teleskop.
Wenn übrig bleibt, eine kleine Bewegung, dieser Spiegel wird auch das korrigieren.
Es ist nicht mehr egal, ob das von Atmosphäre kommt oder vom Teleskop.
Aber diese Adaption dieses vierten Spiegels, das ist ja auch ein Spiegel.
Ja, eigentlich sind es sechs Sektoren.
Man sieht das von außen wie ein Spiegel, aber es ist gemacht mit sechs Sektoren.
Es gibt auch einen ganz kleinen Raum zwischen diesen zwei Sektoren.
Und die Adaption bedeutet, dass
aber hier auch wirklich die Spiegelfläche selber verändert werden kann.
Gebogen wird.
Da wird es wirklich gebogen.
Wirklich gebogen, ja.
Während bei dem großen Spiegel wir mit diesem Dreieck nur die Positionierung
haben, ist bei diesem vierten Spiegel jetzt wirklich eine fein,
granulare Adaption der Spiegelkrümmung selber.
Das heißt, man hat dort diese ganz feinen Aktuatoren, die den Spiegel so entgegen
der Verzerrung der Atmosphäre wird hier wieder aufgelöst.
Ja, in diesen adaptiven Optikspiegel, man biegt das Glas. Das Glas wird gebogen,
deswegen ist es sehr dünn.
Das Glas ist nicht so gut zu biegen, aber es muss sehr dünn sein.
Und bei der M1 ist es nur die einzelnen Segment, die man bewegt.
Wow, also das ist schon wirklich ein krasses Gerät.
Ja, und ein M5 zum Beispiel, der sehr schnell bewegt sein muss. Er ist groß, 2,7 Meter.
Und hier das Problem, man will nicht den Spiegel biegen. Es muss flach bleiben,
aber es muss auch bewegt werden.
Und hier die Herausforderung ist, dass die Oberfläche sich nicht biegt,
wenn man den ganzen Spiegel bewegt.
So gibt es alle möglichen Herausforderungen.
Also jeder Spiegel korrigiert sozusagen einen anderen Aspekt,
um ein stabiles Bild zu haben.
Was kommt da jetzt am Ende bei raus? Also das Licht, was jetzt diesen fünften
Spiegel verlässt, womit wird das jetzt aufgenommen und dann kommen wir ja auch
so ein bisschen zu den Instrumenten.
Da gibt es ja sicherlich mehrere, die man da einschalten kann.
Welcher Frequenzbereich wird von diesem Spiegel jetzt eigentlich eingefangen
und was passiert jetzt an dieser Stelle?
Was wird mit diesem Lichtstrahl, den man jetzt gewonnen hat, der korrigiert ist?
Maximal versucht das Licht einzufangen. Was macht man jetzt damit?
Ja, so ist die Frequenz, das ELT ist konzipiert von zwischen sichtbarer Licht, so blau im Prinzip,
0,4 sogar ein bisschen runter, 0,38 glaube ich,
ich weiß nicht genau, aber ich glaube, sagen wir 0,4 Mikronen Lichtwellenlänge
bis Infrarot und sogar thermisch Infrarot, so 10, 20 Mikronen.
Lichtlänge, Lichtwellenlänge, glaube ich, sagt man.
Sollte sind ein relativ sehr breites Spektrum, aber im optischen,
sagt man, optische, das ist ein optisches Telescom, das ist keine Radio, das ist kein X-Ray.
Optisch plus Infrarot.
Genau. Ja, Infrarot gehört zum Optisch, für die Wissenschaftlichen. Ja, genau.
Und damit die Instrumenten, wie gesagt, Sie sind zurückgegangen.
In sich selbst große Geräte, ein Haus groß im Prinzip, mit viel Spiegel auch drinnen,
viel Komponente, die das Licht in einem Spektrum macht, zum Beispiel.
Normalerweise hat ein Instrument verschiedene Kanäle. Er kann mit Spiegel das
Licht in verschiedene Kanäle bringen, verschiedene Kameras kann man sagen,
die jede einzelne Funktion hat oder Stärke hat.
Entweder das ist ein sehr präzises Bild zu machen, so wie eine Kamera,
andere sind mehr für das Spektrum zu machen, sodass Licht ihre eigene Komponente
in diese verschiedenen Lichtwellen lange zu verteilen.
Und zu messen, was es zum Beispiel für Komponenten, für Atomen oder diese Sterne.
Man kann sie durch das Spektrum erkennen.
Man erkennt, diese Lichtwelle ist die Lichtwelle von Wasserstoff.
Man kann das in dem Spektrum erkennen.
Eigentlich muss man achten, weil mit dieser Redshift, Diese Bewegung,
die Expansion des Universums, diese Lichtwellen werden im Rot verschoben.
Weil die Ausdehnung des Universums halt einfach die Frequenz in die Länge zieht.
Aber wenn man genug davon hat, kann man die schon erkennen und genau auch zum
Beispiel die Entfernung messen durch diese Redshift, diese rote Verschiebung.
Das Instrument hat mehrere Kanäle zur Beobachtung.
Und auch jedes Instrument hat sein eigenes wissenschaftliches Ziel.
Zum Beispiel eine ist mehr für diese Infrarotteile, für 10 bis 20 Mikronenbeobachtung.
Das muss sehr tief gekühlt, das Detektor muss sehr tief gekühlt und andere Linsen
werden gebraucht, weil auf diese Lichtwelle lange muss man andere Materielle nutzen.
Wir haben aktuell drei Instrumente plus ein Adaptive Optics Modul,
weil das Teleskop macht diese Adaptive Optics Korrektion,
aber das ist noch nicht genug für manche Beobachtung und man braucht dann eine
zweite Ebene, noch präziser.
Ist dann ein bisschen kompliziert vielleicht auch das zu erklären aber
die korrektur das man macht im teleskop ist im prinzip für anaxis für für dich
für die stelle in der mitte sagen wir wenn man einen sichtwinkel haben will
die nicht null ist sondern ein bisschen vielleicht ja man will eine ganze galaxie
sehen zum beispiel dann braucht man nicht nur,
in der Mitte korrigieren, aber auch auf der Seite.
Und die Verzerrung zu den Seiten muss man sozusagen auch ausrechnen.
Und wir haben ein Instrument, oder sagen wir, das ist kein echtes Instrument,
weil er beobachtet selber nicht, aber er macht diese Korrektur für die anderen Instrumente.
Verstehe.
Und wenn dieser Lichtstrahl jetzt aus dem M5-Spiegel herauskommt,
sind dann mehrere Instrumente parallel aktiv?
Das heißt, man bricht es nochmal mit so einem Prisma auf und verteilt es an
verschiedene Instrumente oder ist dann immer nur ein Instrument gleichzeitig aktiv?
Noch ein, gleich aktiv und dafür haben wir noch einen Spiegel, das ist der M6,
logischerweise, sechster Spiegel, die diese Lichtstrahlen auf der Seite oder
entweder durchschließt oder auf jeder Seite.
Wir haben drei Instrumente auf jeder Seite vom Telescope, so sechs Plätze im Prinzip.
Und wir haben auch zwei andere Instrumente im Bau oder erst im Design.
Bis aktuell sind sechs Instrumente entwickelt worden, aber erst vier,
inklusive dieses Adaptive Optics Modules.
Ja genau, aber wird jedes Mal eine benutzt.
Das heißt, welches Instrument jetzt gerade zum Einsatz kommt,
hängt dann immer davon ab, was eigentlich genau von wem, weswegen,
aus welchen Gründen beobachtet wird.
Das ist ja immer ein Rennen dann bei den Wissenschaftlern.
Man muss dann beantragen und sagen so, ja, ich würde mir gerne mal diese Galaxis
anschauen, guck doch mal dahin.
Und wenn diese Wissenschaftsgruppe dann den Zuschlag erhält,
dann wird das ja quasi in den Zeitplan aufgenommen.
Das wird angesteuert und dann sagt man, okay, ich hätte aber jetzt gerne dieses
Instrument, weil mich interessiert jetzt der Infrarotteil, aber andere wollen
dann vielleicht einen anderen optischen Bereich oder andere Charakteristika haben.
Absolut richtig, ja.
Nur als einen Einblick zu geben in diesen Prozess,
sind ungefähr dreimal so viele Vorschläge gemacht von der Gemeinschaft,
als es Zeit gibt.
Klar.
Sehr hochgepüttig kompetitiv.
Da wird noch viel geweint werden.
Ja.
Jetzt natürlich die Frage, was sind eigentlich die wissenschaftlichen Ziele?
Was will man jetzt sehen oder was meint man vielleicht entdecken und herausfinden
zu können, was jetzt mit den bisherigen Teleskopen so noch nicht oder nicht
ausreichend realisiert werden konnte?
Weil das steht ja am Anfang dieses ganzen Designs.
Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass die Ingenieure sagen so, 39 Meter irgendwie,
da protzen wir mal richtig, das zeigen wir jetzt mal allen, dass das geht,
sondern es gibt ja in der Regel konkrete wissenschaftliche Ziele,
man will auf irgendwas hinaus und das hat ja auch das ganze Design des Spiegels
und natürlich auch der Instrumente dann mit beeinflusst.
Wo geht die Reise hin, wenn das ELT erstmal am Start ist?
Vielleicht ganz am Anfang würde ich erst sagen, was man oft am Ende sagt,
aber das Wichtigste ist wahrscheinlich, was man nicht weiß, was man finden wird.
Es gibt immer bei solchen neuen Beobachtungsmitteln etwas, das man entdeckt
wird und das man jetzt überhaupt nicht weiß.
Das ist wahrscheinlich vielleicht schon das Wichtigste eigentlich.
Aber trotzdem, natürlich gibt es ganz klare Ziele, wissenschaftliche Ziele.
Eine ist dieses Exoplanet, das aktuell natürlich seit 10, 20 Jahren sehr aktuell
ist, weil das interessiert natürlich alle Menschen zu wissen,
was es für andere Planeten gibt, ob es auch Leben dort gibt und so weiter.
Und hier, das ist wie bei fast allen anderen wissenschaftlichen Zielen,
die Kombination von sehr guter räumlicher Auflösung,
hoher Spektralauflösung, die möglich ist, weil man viel Licht bekommt.
Und weil man viel Licht bekommt, man kann weiter schwache Objekte beobachten
und deswegen weiter in die Vergangenheit gucken, weil es nicht braucht Zeit zu kommen.
Und genau, diese Kombination von drei Sachen, so viel Licht,
kann man weit weg gucken.
Aber auch kann man Spektrum machen mit sehr hoher Auflösung.
Und diese räumliche Auflösung durch die Diffraktion kombiniert mit Adaptive Optics.
Und für Exoplanet damit kann man zum Beispiel mit der räumlichen Auflösung die
Planeten sehen, die nicht zusammen mit dem Licht von Sternen ist.
Man braucht gute Auflösungen, um die zwei auseinanderzunehmen.
Und mit der großen Lichtempfindlichkeit kann man die Atmosphäre von diesem Planeten beobachten.
Die Photon, die kommen von dieser Atmosphäre, kann man die nehmen und auch vielleicht
diese nicht sehr große Spektralauflösung, weil es nicht so viel gibt,
aber trotzdem kann man ein Spektrum machen damit.
Reden wir von einer direkten Beobachtung des Exoplaneten selbst,
unabhängig davon, ob er jetzt vor dem Stern ist oder nicht.
Richtig, weil vor der Sterne, das macht man schon jetzt.
Aber hier ist eine Direktbeobachtung unabhängig von der Sterne.
Ist denn okay, also man geht davon aus, dass das ELT den Planeten wirklich sehen
kann oder bedeutet das ja dann im Prinzip,
also dass das geringe Licht, was eigentlich ja von dem Stern,
um den der Planeten kreist,
von diesem Planeten zurückgeworfen wird, dass man das noch auflösen kann.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Wow. Und damit dann auch…,
Planeten beobachten kann, die sehr weit weg von ihrem Stern entfernt sind.
Also wenn die Planeten sehr nah sind und sehr oft an ihren Sternen vorbeikommen,
die sind ja kaum zu trennen von so einem Stern, wenn die sehr nah dran sind.
Also ich kann mir fast nicht vorstellen, dass man die so beobachten kann,
aber wenn man jetzt sagt, da ist jetzt einer, der sehr weit draußen ist,
was weiß ich, so wie unser Jupiter oder so oder noch weiter,
dass man die also auch unabhängig beobachten kann.
Ja, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich weiß nicht, was die Grenze ist,
aber sicher, du hast recht, es gibt sicher einige, die zu nah sind,
auch für das ELT. Ich weiß nicht, wo die Grenze ist.
Okay, aber man hat auf jeden Fall eine Auflösung, um wirklich den Planeten als
solchen beobachten zu können.
Man ist ja noch nicht so lange her, da hat man überhaupt erstmal Exoplaneten
gefunden, das ist ja alles noch relativ neu.
Und jetzt sind wir schon so auf dem Weg dahin, die Planeten direkt zu beobachten
und nicht nur die Sterne. Irre.
Und dann gibt es auch sehr spannend, finde ich persönlich, ist diese fundamentale
Frage für Dark Matter, Dark Energy, die schwarze Materie und schwarze Energie wahrscheinlich.
Dunkle Energie, Dunkle Materie.
Und man weiß, dass unser Universum expandiert, aber nicht nur expandiert,
sondern sogar beschleunigt.
Das weiß man schon vor ein paar Jahren, das war ein Nobelpreis.
Und aktuell misst man das mit Supernovae. Das sind spezielle Sterne,
die eine Besonderheit haben.
Das sind im Prinzip Sterne, die explodiert haben. Und damit kann man im Prinzip
die Distanz relativ gut messen, aber man braucht verschiedene von dieser Supernovae
in verschiedenen Galaxien.
Eine relativ nahe, eine weiter weg, eine noch weiter weg.
Aber das sind nicht die gleichen Sterne, es gibt schon Ungenauigkeit, weil.
Wir haben ein Modell, wie sich die Supernova entwickelt und damit kann man wissen,
diese Redshift ist zu weit weg, aber grundsätzlich sind es nicht das gleiche Objekt.
Und ich denke, das ELT wird man mit Quasar messen können.
Quasar sind extrem energetische Events, die sehr weit weg sind und die auch
extrem klein sind. Man kann nicht die Durchmesse messen.
Und mit ELT kann man direkt diese Quasar messen, die Distanz.
Und wenn man das über mehrere Jahre macht, Jahrzehnte vielleicht,
dann kann man direkt diese Beschleunigung von Expansionen messen.
Das heißt, das Sun-Age-Test.
Das ist etwas, das die Astronomen versuchen, das zu machen mit dem aktuellen Teleskop.
Aber sie haben nicht genug Photon, das Licht fehlt, nicht genug Licht.
Weil man braucht wirklich viel Licht, um diese Beobachtung zu machen.
Das wird das ELT machbar machen.
Das heißt, mit diesen Quasaren, wenn man die über lange Zeit beobachtet,
kann man korrektere Ergebnisse erzielen in der Einschätzung,
wie weit etwas entfernt ist.
Ja, und mit jedem Quasar, ich meine, es gibt mehrere, die dafür geeignet sind
Und man wird wirklich die Distanz von dieser eigenen Quasar erendet nicht.
Deswegen diese Ungenauigkeit mit Supernova, wo man von einer Supernova zu einer
anderen sehen muss, das hat man nicht.
Das ist die gleiche Quelle, die man über die Jahre beobachtet.
Das heißt, man kann dann genauer bestimmen, wo befindet sich eine Galaxie genau
und das soll dann wiederum Rückschlüsse erlauben für die dunkle Energie,
für die Expansion des Universums.
Ja, genau. Richtig.
Und es gibt auch noch andere Sachen, die ich auch faszinierend finde,
weil sie sind sehr nah an die physische Theorie, ist, ob diese physische Konstante,
es gibt ein paar Konstante in unserem aktuellen Kenntnis von Physik.
Und wir meinen, sie sind konstant, alle Beobachtungen zeigen,
sie scheinen konstant zu sein überall im Universum.
Aber mit ELT kann man das checken. Und wenn das nicht der Fall ist,
wenn man merkt, oh, das ist nicht genau diese Konstante, Zum Beispiel,
ich weiß nicht genau, welche Teilchen ist das, aber es gibt ein Ratio zwischen
irgendwelchen Quark oder Protonen, ich weiß nicht genau, welche Teilchen.
Aber man hat bemerkt, dieses Ratio, das Verhältnis, ist gleich in unserer Theorie.
Aber mit Eltern kann man das checken, ob das der Fall ist.
Die Erfahrungen haben gezeigt, dass wenn man genau misst, dann merkt man oft,
dass, oh, diese Theorie, das war nur eine Vereinfachung, sagen wir.
Ja, das begleitet ja sozusagen die...
Die Kosmologie schon lange und das Verständnis der Welt, dass man nicht weiß,
okay, gilt das, was wir jetzt sehen, also ist unsere derzeitige Annahme,
dass die Dinge immer gleich sind, gilt das wirklich für das ganze Universum?
Ist die Ausdehnung irrelevant oder spielt die eine Rolle?
Ändert sich die Physik in gewisser Hinsicht und ist etwas, was wir konstant
angenommen haben, tatsächlich variabel, aber man merkt das erst,
wenn man noch sehr viel größere Distanzen anschaut.
So wie Einstein sozusagen Newton im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes relativiert hat,
könnte es ja auch sein, dass das, was bisher für alle Berechnungen auch ausgereicht
hat, ich meine, wir können irgendwelche Satelliten ins All schicken und 30 Jahre
später treffen die dann Kometen und da weiß man so, okay,
also unsere Berechnungen sind jetzt so gut, dass das alles hinhaut,
aber würde das auch noch funktionieren, wenn wir jetzt Faktor 1000 oder Faktor
eine Million draufrechnen? das wissen wir nicht unbedingt.
Das heißt, dieser Sandwich-Test benannt nach einem,
Alan Rex Sandwich, das ist sozusagen die Methode, die hier angewendet wird,
um diese Parameter zu bestimmen.
Ja, und es gibt noch mehrere. Natürlich gibt es die Galaxie-Entstehung,
schwarze Löcher auch, ich weiß nicht.
Das war jetzt im Prinzip Ausdehnung, also dunkle Energie bezieht sich ja auf die Ausdehnung.
Dunkle Materie ist ja mehr so die Frage, gibt es Teilchen, die noch Masse haben,
aber die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht sehen können.
Es gibt ja diese Annahme.
Aber inwiefern kann das ELT da helfen?
Man sieht das schon. Ich meine, es gibt diese Gravitational Lensing.
Gravitationslinsen.
Ja, man sieht die und man sieht, es muss viel mehr Mass geben,
hier in der Mitte, um diese Linsen zu erklären.
Es sind Galaxien, die noch weiter weg sind und das Licht ist gebogen.
Und um diese Biege von Licht zu erklären, muss man ein sehr hohes Maß hier haben
und man sieht überhaupt nichts.
Es gibt keine andere Galaxie dort. Es gibt nichts sichtbar.
Deswegen ist diese dunkle Materie.
Und hier auch, ich meine, das ELT wird noch mehr von diesen Linsen beobachten
können und vielleicht besser verstehen.
Also liefert er da einfach nochmal mehr Daten, um das genauer zu untersuchen,
wie es denn nun wirklich aussieht da draußen, weil es ist einfach noch sehr viel unklar.
Glücklicherweise, sonst wäre kein Job für die Astronomen. Und das wäre langweilig.
Das wäre wirklich langweilig, genau.
Was gibt es noch, was man vielleicht herausfinden kann oder wo man hinterher
ist, wo jetzt die Wissenschaftler auch die Zeit beantragen?
Was denkt man, was man noch finden kann?
Ja, schwarze Löcher sind natürlich immer ein Hit, sehr interessant,
aber das ist ein Extremes von unserer Physik oder die Physik,
die wir jetzt kennen oder die Relativität, die generelle Relativität.
Das ist eigentlich ein Problem von der Relativität.
Es ist eine Singularität und man kann nicht wissen, was drin ist.
Und deswegen auch diese Stringtheorie und alle anderen, viele neue Theorien
sind gebaut worden und versuchen das zu lösen, dieses Problem.
Und ein Beispiel, das uns sehr nahe liegt, ist dieser Nobelpreis von 2020.
Ich habe davon schon gesprochen, von Rainer Grenzel und von Max Planck daneben.
Der hat schon das VLTI benutzt und andere Teleskopen, um Laufbahn von Sternen
ganz nah auf dem Schwarzen Loch, die in unserer eigenen Galaxie ist,
hat das gemessen, aber mit ELT kann man noch näher gehen.
Und dieses Mikado-Instrument, das ist eines der ersten Instrumente,
die gebaut wurden, eigentlich sogar von Max Planck.
Dieses Instrument wird auch noch näher gucken und noch genauer diese Laufbahn
messen können und noch mehr Informationen und mehr Genauigkeit bekommen über
diese Eigenschaft von das Schwarzloch und auch die Theorie, die Relativität.
Das ist ein anderer. Und das ist auch durch diese räumliche Auflösung und diese
Lichtempfindlichkeit, die ELT hat, kann man das noch weiterentwickeln.
Ja, spannend. Also warst du denn selber schon mal vor Ort bei der Baustelle?
Ja, ein paar Mal, als es noch nichts gab zum Beispiel. Das war diese erste Steinseremonie
mit dem Präsidenten von Chile.
Damals war Bachelet.
Und das war wirklich symbolisch das Anfang von der Baustelle.
Und ich war auch letzten Januar dort und dort habe ich meinen ersten Eindruck,
weil ich war dazwischen nie.
Und ja, du gehst rein in diese Gebäude und mein Gefühl,
ich gehe in meine Kathedrale des 21.
Wissenschaftlichen Jahrhunderts. Das ist wirklich wie ein Kathedral.
Du merkst, oh, diese Dimension ist nicht normal.
Etwas hat die Menschen gebracht, diese unglaubliche große Sache zu bauen.
Wie in einem Kathedral, wo das mehr die geistige.
Kraft von Manchheit ist. Hier ist mehr diese Geistsache zu verstehen.
Und ich fand, es gibt einen richtigen Parallel zwischen den zwei und vielleicht
können wir ein bisschen zu viel nehmen die Philosophie.
Ich weiß nicht immer, ob am Ende müsste ich in diese Richtung gehen,
Aber für mich Astronomie ist...
Hat diese sehr wichtige Eigenschaft oder Ziel, dass die Menschheit mehr bewusst werden.
Mehr bewusst von der ganzen Welt und auch unsere Kondition hier,
die sehr empfindlich ist.
Ja, weil da draußen ist alles zu warm.
Nicht genug Luft. Und wir sind diese kleine Planete.
Ich glaube, es ist sehr wichtig für die Menschheit, durch die Astronomie dieses
Gefühl zu bekommen, dass wir unglaublich Glück haben, auf dieser Erde zu sein.
Man muss diese Erde schützen, man muss unseren Menschen auch richtig umgehen
und nicht uns gegenseitig stütten.
Für mich hat Astronomie dieses große Ziel, das die Religion hat.
Auch die spirituelle Versuch zu verstehen, wo wir sind, warum sind wir da und ja,
so wie gesagt, das ist für mich was mich treibt eigentlich ich bin sehr glücklich,
mein ganzes Leben in diesem Bereich gearbeitet zu haben, weil ich finde, das ist wichtig,
obwohl natürlich ich verstehe auch die Leute, die sagen warum wichtig ist Essen.
Auf dem Tisch.
Ja, auf dem Tisch.
Kann man auch verstehen, aber es ist auch immer wieder, also mir geht es ja
auch ähnlich, ich meine,
es ist der Moment, wo man sich so mit dem Weltall beschäftigt und dann so Schritt
für Schritt und das ist ja auch ein bisschen mein Weg mit diesem Podcast,
der ich am Anfang irgendwie nicht wusste, in welcher Reihenfolge ich jetzt die
Planeten aufzählen sollte und dann.
Lernt man Schritt für Schritt kennen, wie man diese ganzen Dimensionen überhaupt
anordnen soll und eine Galaxie kann man sich schon fast gar nicht vorstellen,
aber auch so einen Haufen von Galaxieclustern kann man sich nicht vorstellen
und selbst wenn man das schon irgendwie erfasst hat, dann geht es doch noch
irgendwie immer weiter und wir wissen, dass es eine Grenze gibt,
die wir nie beobachten können.
Also selbst wenn wir alles verstehen, was wir beobachten können,
wissen wir auch schon jetzt, dass es irgendwas gibt, was wir nie beobachten
können werden und das schafft dann schon so eine gewisse Demut,
weil ich denke auch dieses Bild,
was unsere Science Fiction liefert,
die ist natürlich unterhaltsam und aufregend und auch auf ihre Art und Weise
philosophisch, aber auch unrealistisch.
Weil man fliegt jetzt nicht mal zwei Stunden mit einem Raumschiff irgendwo hin
und dann hat man wieder einen bewohnbaren Planeten und da laufen auch irgendwie
menschenähnliche Wesen herum,
sondern es ist bisher noch nicht mal gelungen, in unserer unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft
auch nur ähnliches Leben zu finden oder überhaupt irgendetwas,
was man Leben nennen kann,
zu finden, sodass es in zunehmendem Maße wie ein großer Zufall wirkt,
dass es uns in dieser Form überhaupt gibt, ohne zu wissen.
Wie wahrscheinlich dieser Zufall im ganzen Universum überhaupt ist.
Und das, ja, ich benutze gerne das Wort so Demut, weil man dann halt einfach
merkt, so wichtig sind wir irgendwie offensichtlich dann doch wieder nicht.
Es sei denn, man nimmt halt diesen Zufall als Grund für Wichtigkeit daher. Und das.
Ich stelle auch immer wieder fest, dass einfach die gesamte Raumfahrtszene, alle Wissenschaftler,
alle Techniker immer sehr beseelt davon sind, so eigentlich dieses Wissen zu
generieren und diese Demut dann auch irgendwie in sich tragen.
Auch bei den Astronauten finde ich das immer wieder.
Ja, obwohl einige wollen einfach weg von der Erde, wenn die kaputt werden.
Das finde ich absolut nicht die richtige Einstellung.
Aber man muss auch respektieren, es gibt auch so viele verschiedene Arten zu
denken und sein Leben zu gestalten. Es ist alles okay.
Aber als Gemeinschaft, als Gesellschaft ist es glaube ich wichtig dass man dieses Bewusstsein erhöht,
um uns selber zu kümmern und dass es uns besser geht als Menschen als Individuen,
aber es gibt Menschen die auch das Problem haben, wenn man über diese unglaubliche
Dimension spricht sie bekommen Angst,
weil das ist unvorstellbar und man bekommt Angst, das ist nicht mein Fall vielleicht habe ich Glück,
ich verstehe das auch ja, genau.
Deswegen hilft es wahrscheinlich, sich auch ein bisschen da schlau zu machen
und sich damit zu beschäftigen, weil dann wird das in gewisser Hinsicht auch normal.
Genau.
Neutronensterne sind meine Freunde. Bertrand, super Abschluss für dieses Gespräch.
Vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Dankeschön auch für die Einladung.
Ja, und das war's zum ELT und alles, was damit zu tun hat.
Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und sage Tschüss und bis bald.